over the past few days evidence is
emerging that coronavirus models may
have overestimated the pandemic even
hard-hit areas like Italy and New York
may be turning the corner earlier than
projected there is a light at the end of
the tunnel and a whole lot of people
will have a whole lot of explaining to
do as to why we just destroyed the
global economy we will examine the value
of hindsight and how shoulda coulda
woulda will affect the 2020 election
then despite months of mainstream media
insistence that the Wuhan virus has
nothing whatsoever to do with the
shadowy Wuhan Institute of Virology news
reports suggests a link between the two
we will take a look at the latest and
how a conspiratorial press has abused
the term conspiracy theory all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
some good news isn't that nice to report
for a change Italy may have turned the
corner now we're just looking at numbers
from Friday and Saturday right now we'll
have more numbers obviously coming out
later this morning Italy on Friday
reported 766 new deaths that's no good
brings the total up to 14,000 681 that's
no good but the fact that it was only
600 766 deaths and that more than that
shows that we're now seeing a slowdown
in Italy over multiple days infections
grew from Thursday to Friday by 2.8
percent also doesn't sound great except
that is lower than it was growing before
so before the rate was 3% now it's down
to 2.8 looks like we're seeing a
slowdown and the number of people who
got the virus and then we're sick and
then recovered also jumped pretty high
on Friday in Italy to 19,000 758 so it
looks as though we can say with some
confidence Italy has peaked you know
we've all been doing about flattening
the curve it now seems to have gone over
the top of the curve and it's on the way
down really good news for us is that may
also be true in New York it may not be
true in New York Andrew Cuomo the
governor there has been cautious to say
listen we had a little bit of a slowdown
that might just be a blip though it
might go back up again but there does
seem to be the light at the end of the
tunnel there so New York's count of
daily coronavirus deaths fell for the
first time on Saturday compared to
Friday so on Friday there were 630
deaths in New York on Saturday there
were 594 deaths which is significantly
down if you're talking about 36 deaths
down to the number 594 new
hospitalizations were also down they
were way down they went down to 574 on
Saturday compared to 1095 on Friday this
trend holds for daily ICU admissions
that decreased from 395 on Friday to 250
on Saturday so again way down intubation
fell
a little bit but down from 351 on Friday
down to 316 on Saturday and probably
best of all the discharge rate went way
way up to 1709 on Saturday
compared to 1502 on Friday so pretty
much every number coming out of New York
got better from Friday to Saturday might
have just been a blip it might might
still might spike again this week but
across the board hospitalizations ICU
discharge mmm death all of those numbers
going in the right direction at least
from Friday to Saturday now who knows
we'll see over the next few days if New
York really has peaked even if New York
has not peaked we are seeing evidence
that that malaria drug that has been
around for a long time that President
Trump and others have touted as showing
promise on treating coronavirus actually
is doing a great job of treating
coronavirus here is just one physician
who is seeing a lot of coronavirus
patients who has been prescribing it to
his patients saying that in virtually
all cases hydroxychloroquine has worked
clinically with our patients is that it
really only works in conjunction with
zinc so the hydroxyl croakin opens the
zinc channel zinc goes into the cell it
then blocks the replication of the
cellular machinery so it has to be used
in conjunction with zinc we are seeing
some clinical responses in that regard
there are people that take it regularly
for other disease processes we have to
be cautious and mindful that we don't
prescribe it for patients who have kovat
that are well it really should be
reserved for people that are really sick
in the hospital or at home very sick
that need that medication otherwise
we're gonna blow through our supply the
patient that take it regularly for other
disease from what Boyd you're saying is
you're prescribing it and it is working
for kovat 19 patients every patient i
prescribed it to has been very very ill
and within eight to 12 hours
they were basically symptom free that's
a pretty amazing endorsement the person
was very very ill and with 8 to 12 hours
it was done it was all better notice he
has a word of caution here he says look
if you're not showing symptoms if you're
not very sick do not take this drug
but he's not saying don't take this drug
because the drug will make you sicker
he's saying don't take the drug cuz the
drug is so damn good that we don't want
to burn through our whole supply and
because some people take the drug for
other reasons not just for coronavirus
in fact that's the whole reason this
drug is working is because it doesn't
need to go through an extensive FDA
approval process it's already gone
through that process the drug has
already been around it's not like
scientists had to discover a new drug in
a lab and then test it on animals then
test it on people then go through this
whole process and within 18 months we
still don't have a drug for coronavirus
the drug has been tested for a long time
and it appears to be working on
coronavirus this is great news right of
course it is and nobody could be more
furious about it than the mainstream
media we'll get to that in a second
first got to thank our friends over at
ring you know these days when you get a
lot of things being delivered to the
door I bet you're not going out quite as
much you really want to know who that is
knocking your door okay who that is
ringing the bell ring gives you
protection at every corner and it helps
you create custom affordable security
for your home ring detects motion when
people come onto your property and rings
video doorbells let you answer the door
and check in on your home from anywhere
at any time ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world maybe you're at the office maybe
you're on vacation man you're just
getting the heck out of Dodge and you
want to check in on your house well you
can if it's a surprise package delivery
if it's a surprise visitor if heaven
forfend it's your mother-in-law you'll
get an alert you'll be able to see hear
and speak to them all from your phone
get a special offer right now on one of
rings video doorbells when you go to
ring calm / Knolls canna wles
start building custom security for your
home today again go to ring.com / Knolls
canada wles
you will feel like you are in the future
and you'll be able to check in on your
home from anywhere this is this is good
news I know we haven't had a lot of good
news recently but good news on
hospitalizations on the death rate on
this drug working and the media are so
upset specifically on the drug you know
president Trump does
these daily press conferences he is his
own press secretary they're the best
stuff on TV they are even slightly
better than Tiger king and tiger King is
a great show
we got a few press conferences to catch
up on over the weekend the biggest
takeaway I had from all of them is how
much the press does not want this
pandemic to get better they seem furious
when the drugs work they seem furious
when the numbers are going in the right
direction
in fact one reporter is asking President
Trump if he thinks it's really
responsible to go out there on
television every day and tell people
that there's actually hope in the form
of this new drug while you acknowledge
you're not a physician
you do promote these medicines
extensively here how do you not go so
far as to be giving medical advice and
you said yesterday you might take some
of these medicines even though you don't
have symptoms are you still planning to
do that and how do you calibrate being
enthusiastic yeah and not playing doctor
because I want people to live and I'm
seeing people dying and I've see people
that are going to die without it and you
know the expression when that's
happening they should do what really do
we have to lose we also have this
medicine it's been tested for many years
for malaria and for lupus so it's been
out there so it's a very strong powerful
medicine but it doesn't kill people he's
almost flabbergasted I think you look at
his confusion you see mr. president your
words carry so much weight why on earth
would you tout this drug that's shown
great efficacy at treating coronavirus
because I want people to live you
monsters do you not want people to live
think about how perverse that is the
mainstream media know of this drug which
has been shown to be effective at
treating the global pandemic that there
is currently no cure for and no vaccine
for and the press are angry the Trump
would tell people about the drug look
also at how the press wants to have it
both ways with Trump they get angry with
Trump
that he's not acting fast enough right
they say they're the administration's
bungled response to coronavirus they're
not working fast enough they didn't have
an answer in place and then the press
gets angry that Trump is acting too fast
they say we had no response to this
virus you have no cure for this virus
okay well we've got a cure now you can't
have a cure that's terrible you haven't
gone through 18 months of clinical
testing it seems pretty clear they just
don't want the problem to go away I
thought Trump gave a very good answer
the reporters were not pleased with that
answer actually the reporters came back
and asked the same question again
phrased even more offensively but then
the next reporter then asked the
question as to why those pesky elected
politicians keep leading our politics
and making these decisions instead of
just turning over all of their power to
the scientists to science itself the
doctors who are treating coronavirus
patients they have the medical expertise
to determine whether or not they should
person subscribe
hi-c and many of them and there are
already clinical trials in place looking
at hydroxychloroquine so if you won't
finish in about a year why not just let
the science speak for itself why are you
promoting this drug not you know what
I'm trying to do what you're saying
about your everyday rights are talking
about the benefits I want them to try
and it may work and it may not work but
if it doesn't work it's nothing lost by
doing it nothing because we know
long-term what I want I want to save
lives and I don't want it to be in a lab
for the next year and a half as people
are dying all over the place out there
doctors already able to prescribe it all
lately I don't want to wait a year to
have to find out and only CNN would ask
that question fake news go ahead so true
well actually let me let me caveat that
a little bit it's true that CNN is such
fake news that they would ask that
question but a lot of reporters in this
room are asking this kind of ridiculous
question with that reporters question
boils down to is mr. president why are
you being the president mr. president
why are you showing political leadership
and giving him
Americans hope and trying to point them
in the right direction why aren't look
and then Trump answers he says because I
want to save lives he says look the drug
is out there okay
the report says it like grudgingly the
drug is out there fine okay there's a
cure for coronavirus or if there's not a
cure at least there's a good treatment
for it but you don't need to promote it
you don't need to tell people there's a
cure we were hoping this pandemic would
go on for six months we were hoping if
we were lucky this thing would go on for
18 months and then you would lose the
election and then Joe Biden would become
president he probably wouldn't even be
aware of it if he got elected but then
then we could do whatever we want and
now you're going around our backs you
you pesky Donald Trump and you're giving
people hope and showing them that there
is a light at the end of the tunnel how
dare you mr. president
why not let science speak for itself
guess what science doesn't act on its
own that's the other side of this it's
not like you just you I don't know you
put a bunch of microscopes in a lab and
you have a couple white coats hung on
the wall and then science happens okay
science is led by people who follow the
scientific method and then once the
scientists do the science see things
then you have drugs which now we have
and then it is up to our leaders to
promote those drugs it is up to our
leaders to tell us that those drugs are
available to communicate that to us to
lead in the crisis and the press hates
it the Trump is leading right now and
they apparently hate it that things are
going better than before but the press
is not just upset that people have
access to medicine that can treat
coronavirus there now openly furious
that people have access to food we will
get to that in a second first I got to
thank our friends over at Rock Auto you
know how much I love Rock Auto
rockauto.com is just so much easier than
walking into an auto parts store and
then someone demanding quick answers of
you like like is your Odyssey an XL or
an e X or an LX oh I don't even know all
these different letters and then usually
the auto parts store doesn't even have
the port you want so they just go online
they probably go to Rock Auto frankly
and then they find out that they order
it and then they charge you twice
as much that's crazy why would you do
that if you have the internet you have
access to the rockauto.com catalog at
your desk and in your pocket and guess
what if you're like me you don't know
anything about cars
even you will be able to navigate the
rockauto.com catalog it's just that
simple they always have the lowest price
possible they're not always they're not
changing prices like a bunch of gimmicks
they just always have the lowest one
possible it's great why spend up to
twice as much on the same parts go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Knowles in there how did you hear about
us box and then they will note that we
sent you so the press very upset that
people now have access to medicine for
coronavirus if they can't stop the
medicine from getting out there they at
least want to stop people from getting
access to food I'm not joking I'm not
exaggerating
one reporter chastised President Trump
for allowing grocery stores to remain
open obviously we know anyone can spread
the disease all right right so why even
not have a few businesses open why not
just shut everything down there a
grocery store that are open fast-food
places why you can take a little chance
to Charlotte we're gonna have to it will
answer that question later all I can say
is that right now things are looking
really good and opening up with a bang
will be a great thing and there's nobody
gonna be happier than me mr. president
why not let people just starve to death
in the apartment pods that the governors
are forcing me to remain oh why are you
allowing people suffering to be
alleviated it is pretty clear at this
point as if it wasn't clear from the
beginning some of us knew this from the
beginning but at this point it is
undeniable the press does not want this
pandemic to lift they don't they want
the hysteria to remain just as high as
they all ginned it up they want the pain
to become more intense they want to hide
the fact that there's an effective drug
they want to keep you from getting
groceries so that you go hungry they
want there to be maximum chaos because
they realize that by maximizing
political pain during this pandemic they
are helping themselves politically and
they are hurting their number-one enemy
Donald Trump politically
that you know I usually try not to use
terms like enemy when I'm talking about
domestic politics it was Ronald Reagan
who said when we're talking about
Democrats and Republicans no one has
enemies we only have opponents but I'm
beginning to think for the left they
have an enemy for instance when you're
think about coronavirus you would think
that okay maybe you disagree with Trump
or you like Trump but he's not the enemy
the enemy is China which is 100%
responsible for spreading this pandemic
and yet when you look at the left-wing
press they are constantly covering for
China they can't get enough of it and
they are constantly attacking Trump and
trying to make it as though Donald Trump
put on a white lab coat went into a lab
in Wuhan and concocted this corona virus
by the way we'll get to the connection
between this virus and that lab in Wuhan
in in just a moment regardless of all
that the evidence is that things are
getting better and increasingly the the
evidence is showing that the doomsday
models that we were all told 2 million
Americans dead or more were wrong and
people are bringing up now even some
reporters or bringing up what to do
about those models and you're about to
see this conversation shift rapidly from
we have to believe the models we have to
believe the most extreme models to the
models were wrong why did you guys get
it wrong here's a reporter putting that
question to President Trump some of the
models that you guys are using the AI
hme model in particular has been very
accurate when it comes to projecting
deaths over the last couple of days but
there's a couple of other metrics that
they seem to be pretty far off on
specifically hospital beds are you guys
can you know happy with the models
you're currently using is there any need
to adjust those well it's turning out
that we need less hospital beds that's
what you're talking about and that's
what we well we may have models but
we've been sort of saying that in New
York we were saying we think you're
gonna need less now let's hope that
continues but right down I heard
Governor Cuomo this morning and he was
saying less hospital beds also less
death that was a very big thing first
time less death today then yesterday
right that's a big thing but also less
hospital beds that means less patients
because basically it's less patients
this is such a dishonest new narrative
that is just today emerging from the
mainstream median you're gonna see it
for weeks now which is initially they
attacked Trump because he was under
estimating the virus and now pretty soon
you're gonna see them attack Trump for
overestimating the virus why aren't you
doing more why did you do so much and
they're gonna do it with a completely
straight face they're gonna do it
without blinking that's how you used to
pushing a narrative these people are
this is good news I guess right they
don't need as many hospital beds as they
thought they needed they don't need a
broader 11th cent this hospital ship to
New York to treat all the people who
don't have corona virus they figured
they could get all the otherwise healthy
people treated on the ship and then all
the hospitals would be used for
coronavirus now they're actually using
the ship for some people with corona
virus because all the other deaths and
injuries are way way down because no
one's allowed to leave their apartments
and it is good news to say there are
fewer people in the hospital than we
thought there are fewer people getting
sick than we thought it's it is good
news but there is a downside to that
the downside is hurray look at how great
we did we destroyed the global economy
for no reason
alright that's assuming the best case
that the models really were overblown is
some people were suggesting weeks ago
not naming any names not raising any
hands but that is great news right
because fewer people then are sick but
then there is a political accountability
question which is why did we just shut
down the global economy wire why did 10
million people lose their jobs within
just two weeks who knows what that
number is going to be by the end of this
week when we get the numbers on Thursday
so good on the health front a little
tougher on the political front president
Trump is already trying to get ahead of
this narrative he's already trying to
distance himself from the models he came
out at the last press conference and he
said look I've never worked with models
well at least not those kind of models
hundreds of thousands of people
today you know what I want to do I want
to come way under the Morrow's the
professionals did the models I was never
involved in a model but it's this kind
of a model like well look at least not
this kind of a model okay maybe you've
all seen Milani a beautiful lady okay
but other kind of models I'm not
involved in a really smart line also
politically smart for Trump to distance
himself from those models that he
initially showed some skepticism toward
that he has repeatedly said he didn't
think the doomsday scenario was
necessarily going to happen this is
going to be the next great debate okay
this coronavirus pandemic and probably
even more so the global shut down that
has resulted from it is the biggest
event to happen to our country in our
world since 9/11 it's the most
significant event even after 9/11 which
was an epoch changing event we didn't
shut down the global economy for two
months or three months or however long
this is going to go on okay 2020 the
2020 election is now about this a month
ago it was about the greatest economy in
the world and unemployment and Trump's
mean tweets and all that stuff now it is
about this and the lead-up to this and
the fallout from this Joe Biden is
already trying to rewrite history to
make the case that he would have handled
coronavirus better than Trump will get
to his case which as you might expect is
pretty weak in just a moment but first I
got to thank our friends over at Abe are
you restless these days are you having
trouble sleeping
I know a lot of people are if you're
having trouble falling and staying
asleep it's time to try AB AB sleep is a
wearable solution that fits over the
forehead and gently cools the forehead
to reduce those racing thoughts allowing
people who suffer from sleeplessness to
drift more comfortably into a deeper
more restorative sleep the minds normal
way of dealing with stress and
challenges is to be on guard or more
vigilant the brain imaging studies
followed by 3,800 nights of clinical
studies by renowned sleep researchers
revealed a revolutionary new way to
sleep I've tried
I really really like this thing because
it's so simple it's not habit-forming
it's not a drug that you're gonna get
addicted to it cools your brain down and
this very cool headband and this gadget
you've just got to try it to believe it
AB sleep understands the uncertainty you
may be experiencing at this time they
want to help you can get $25 off your
order right now by using promo code
Knowles can to wles to save you can
continue to try ever risk free for 60
nights to confirm it's the best solution
you've been looking for
try AB calm / Knowles let a bit help you
get the sleep you need and remove the
risk from your purchase TR why EBV calm
/ Knowles try AB calm / Knowles and use
the promo code Knowles to save order
today with everything going on get the
sleep that you need and deserve remember
Joe Biden
I barely remember Joe Biden Joe Biden I
guess he's he's running for president
Joe Biden is already trying to change
history and say that he would have
handled coronavirus much better than
Trump here is Joe Biden criticizing
Trump were not shutting down travel from
China sooner got to go faster than
slower and we started off awfully slow
he indicated that I complimented him on
on dealing with China well you know 45
nations had already moved to keep
blocked China's personnel from being
able to come the United States before
the president moved so it's just it's
about pace it's about it's about the
urgency and I don't think there's been
enough of it that is an unbelievable
criticism now it's gonna skate by people
who only watch the mainstream media it's
going to skate by people who were kind
of casually paying attention to politics
frankly it's gonna skate by most people
because most people I think have
forgotten that Joe Biden's even running
for president at this point they've
forgotten about the whole election all
of the news cycle has been about
coronavirus and Joe Biden is
particularly good at revising history
and lying with a straight face not even
because he's so deceitful and
duplicitous but really just cuz he has
no regard for the truth he just says
falsehoods with total ease with total
talent and skill just flows right out of
them so
for instance what he just said 45
Nations cut travel from China before the
United States did that's just not true I
don't even know how to refute that
because I have no idea where he even got
that figure from it's just completely
pulled out of thin air
but the most dishonest part of that
statement is that Joe Biden it would
have shut down travel from China much
faster
we have video recordings we know for a
fact that when Donald Trump shut down
travel from China early in January he
was pilloried for it from the left
specifically from Joe Biden who said the
shutting down travel from China was a
bad idea and it was xenophobic
coronavirus emanated from China a
national emergency and you know
worldwide alerts the American people
need to have a president who they can
trust what he says about it that he is
going to act rationally about it and
almost like this this is where credibly
a president is most needed as he
explains what we should and should not
do this is no time for Donald Trump's
record of hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia there it is
now's not the time for that awful Trump
xenophobia that says that we're allowed
to decide who comes into our country and
maybe even though we take the highest
number of immigrants anywhere in the
world maybe we could slightly reduce
that and it would be okay or maybe
during a pandemic we should shut down
travel from the place where the pandemic
started you know crazy ideas like that
he said we can't do that we got to leave
the borders open Trump said no now we've
got the pandemic which probably one of
the most important things to stopping
the spread of this virus was shutting
down travel from China and all of a
sudden Joe Biden comes he says yeah I
didn't shut down travels soon enough
does Joe Biden just forget what he said
possibly
I guess he might forget what he said he
clearly doesn't have a grip on very much
these days in the way of either
political issues or his own memory but
the media are already playing into this
we'll get to how that is in in just one
moment
first I got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube
by the way I also want to give a little
plug out right now glenn beck has a new
book out called arguing with socialists
and once we move past this coronavirus
thing we're gonna probably spend the
rest of the you're arguing with
socialists so it's a good book to get a
primer on that you can get that book now
on amazon or wherever wherever you buy
fine books and if you haven't had a
chance to check out the all access live
show you should check it out so it's
been a lot of fun that's happening every
day at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
it's I call it a show it's not even
really a show we just turned a webcam on
and we hang out last time we were doing
everything for him I was talking about
what drink I was about to make and
answering some personal questions to
reading Dante cuz someone asked me a
question about Dante it's kind of just
whatever we're really hanging out it's
meant for our all-access members but we
are opening it up during this quarantine
to all of our members so come check it
out we should all be hanging out during
this isolation anyway if you are not
even a basic member you got to go to
daily wire.com slash subscribe we'll be
back with a whole lot more
so the media are already playing into
this Joe Biden revisionist history on
coronavirus on his whole political
career on the main issues of 2020 and
they are pushing this to Donald Trump
you know people forget about Joe Biden
because he's just such a secondary news
story at this point and he's such a weak
candidate to begin with that all the
focus is on Trump so the press are
trying to get Joe Biden back in the
conversation they asked President Trump
about Biden's attacks on him and Trump's
answer has been characteristically
savage anything look here's people
here's professionals from the Democrat
responsible for the coronavirus but he's
responsible for failing to prepare our
nation to respond to it how do you do
that he didn't write that that was done
by a Democrat operative he doesn't write
he doesn't he's probably not even
watching right now and if he is he
doesn't understand what he's watching so
it's it's like it keeps following in the
path of his attack since Joe Biden
nearly clinched the nomination or put
himself on the way to get the nomination
or he says look if Joe Biden gets
elected they say Joe Biden's a little
more moderate doesn't matter Joe's not
gonna be President they're gonna put Joe
in a home okay Joe's gonna be in a home
watching TV it's fine it's he's not
gonna know what's going on but that's
okay it's gonna be all of his staff and
his cabinet running things and that's
true Joe Biden does not write his own
tweets Donald Trump writes his own
tweets how do we know that well one
because he's been doing that for as long
as Twitter's been around and he gets
himself in trouble for it too on that
point his staff very often doesn't like
what he's tweeting because it creates
political headaches for them three there
are some kind of random misspellings
just the way that you and I when we text
we misspell things did you just do it
really quickly on your phone he's
writing it right Trump is in command of
this and the coronavirus has really
shown it that guy is in charge
okay that guy love him or hate him agree
with him or disagree with him he knows
what he's doing
Joe Biden that's not the case he can't
get a word out of his mouth without
flubbing it okay Joe is fine on Twitter
because other people are writing his
tweets for him
Joe is fine on podcasts because other
people are speeding it up for one
they're literally speeding up the pace
of his voice and theirs they're editing
it extensively so that you don't have
the arms and the awes and the weird
things he's saying it's if they've
actually done it too much it moves too
fast and it's too tightly edited that
you can hear that there's nowhere even
to breathe in in the podcast not that
anyone's gonna be listening to that
podcast but Joe just speaking
off-the-cuff is awkward and usually
incoherent he's been going on friendly
media to try to get his message out it's
mostly turned into nonsensical
blathering here's Joe Biden on ABC News
with former Clinton communications
director George Stephanopoulos doesn't
get more friendly than that and Joe
still can barely see his way through the
interview we cannot let this we've never
allowed any crisis from the Civil War
straight through to that pandemic of 17
all the way route 16 we have never never
let our democracy sakes
second fiddle way that we can both have
a democracy and the elections and at the
same time correct to public health can
anybody tell me what that means
could anybody tell me from the beginning
to the end of that clip and since we had
in the civil and the the and the flu and
we've always been having and have our
cake and not but make hay while the Sun
shines and 30 days has September April
June and November
public health I think the point at the
very end you could see he got to his
talking point which is we can protect
our freedoms but we can protect public
health nothing he said in that statement
up until that point which he didn't even
totally get out I'm just reading into
what he I think was trying to say
nothing up until that point in that
statement had anything to do with that
the guy doesn't
know what's happening right now okay
does it it's not even just an age thing
Joe Biden has always been a bumbling
jumbling not all that with it
glad-handing empty suit of a politician
but it's gotten especially bad now
because he's not even the man he was
four years ago Joe Biden now cannot even
remember how many grandkids he has and
frankly it's probably worse than that
it's probably the case that Joe Biden
can remember how many grandkids he has
but he just doesn't want to acknowledge
one of them because one of his grandkids
is recently born within the last couple
of years and is the illegitimate child
that his son Hunter had with a stripper
and Joe Biden doesn't want to even
acknowledge that grandchild here's Joe
it's been changing every few days but
here's Joe recently on air saying that
he's got five grandchildren I've been
doing that forever though there's a
there's a deal we have I have five
grandchildren and uh okay that is not
true like many things that Joe Biden
says it's just factually not true Joe
Biden has seven grandchildren now Joe
says five grandchildren he forgot about
two of them okay
maybe Joe is just losing it a little bit
so in the next interview Joe Biden has
his wife Jill on Jill clearly a little
bit more with it but even Jill doesn't
seem to remember how many grandchildren
they have Jill says the number is just
six so my name is Jill miss my husband
Joe and your children may not know but
we have three children and we have six
grandchildren still not true you have
seven grandchildren now Jill just can't
rely on the excuse that she's lost her
marbles
I don't think Jill's lost her marbles
but Beau Biden Joe Biden's late son had
two kids hunter Biden Joe Biden's
degenerate son has five kids they appear
now I mean if it were just Joe I'd say
he forgot the number
but because Jill is saying this also
wrong number different wrong number it
seems to me that they are just leaving
at Hunter Biden's illegitimate child who
was born in August of 2018 Biden you'll
recall has been in a child support
battle over this kid because Hunter
Biden is a deadbeat dad and he doesn't
want to pay child support to the mother
of one of his children so now we see
it's not just that hunter Biden is a
degenerate when it comes to this kid Joe
and Jill are - Joe and Jill it would
appear are refusing to acknowledge one
of their grandchildren because they they
don't like the fact that this child was
born under difficult circumstances
that's an ugly thing and it actually
matters to his campaign I'm not just
digging up family dirt here for the sake
of it it matters to the campaign because
Joe Biden's whole campaign is I'm gonna
restore dignity to the office of the
President Joe Biden's entire campaign
beginning to end is Donald Trump says
mean things and I say nice things Donald
Trump is a mean guy and I'm a nice guy
so in order for that campaign to hold
any weight Joe Biden has to be a nice
guy but nice guys don't refuse to
acknowledge one of their grandchildren
because they don't like the
circumstances of his birth okay this is
a bad look it's a very ugly look for Joe
Biden and it's gonna come back to haunt
him if if they were smart I think
probably what Joe and Jill are thinking
is let's not even acknowledge the kid
because that's gonna bring up more
headaches it's gonna get it into the
news maybe it'll screw up the child
support and paternity lawsuits that have
been going on
that's short-sighted thinking it's a
much worse look for them to callously
refuse to acknowledge one of their
grandkids than to say yeah we have this
grandkid he was born under strange
circumstances all families have some
difficulties but we love our all of our
grandkids including this one but they
haven't done that now moving beyond Joe
who is even now he's got the best
political opportunity in his entire life
global pandemic you could pin a lot of
it on Trump if he if he wanted to twist
the facts and he still can't do it
successfully
speaking of 2020 and how hindsight is
20/20
we are now beginning to get a better
picture of how this virus originated
okay and it's making the Conservatives
who were skeptical look pretty good and
it's making China and China's
propagandists in the mainstream media
look pretty bad so this idea has been
floated for a little while now that it's
a hell of a coincidence that this virus
begins in a Wuhan wet market allegedly
and Wuan is one of the very few places
on earth that has a high level virology
Institute where China studies very
infectious and dangerous diseases
specifically coronavirus diseases what a
weird coincidence huh oh well and the
mainstream media I kid you not they've
been saying since the beginning yep it's
just a weird coincidence and if you say
it's not a coincidence if you say it's
there's something more going on then
you're a terrible person and a racist
and a bigot and a conspiracy theorist so
here's Tom cotton a couple months ago
floating this theory or not I guess
about a month ago a little over a month
ago
floating this theory that perhaps
there's a link between the wuhan virus
and the Wuhan Institute of I Rolla G we
also know that just a few miles away
from that food market is China's only
biosafety level 4 super laboratory that
researches human infectious diseases now
we don't have evidence that this disease
originated there but because of China's
duplicity and dishonesty from the
beginning we need to at least ask the
question to see what the evidence says
and China right now is not giving any
evidence on that question at all so this
super lab that you refer to this super
lab is the only one of its kind in this
area in Wuhan and the province that that
area and and what do they do at this
super lab it's unclear Mariya
we have such laboratories ourselves in
the United States run by our military in
large part done for preventive purposes
we're trying to discover vaccines or
to protect our own soldiers China is
obviously very secretive about what
happens at the Wuhan laboratory we don't
know again where this virus originated
that's why it's so important that we at
least ask the questions and get the
evidence but China continues to block
our ability to ask those questions and
get that evidence totally measured
totally reasonable he's not saying that
she shouldn't ping through on a lab coat
and created this bioweapon and unleashed
on the world he's saying there might be
a link between the blue Han Institute of
biology and the virus that began in
whoo-hah and we should look into that
and even if it was an accident we should
look into that
now lots of evidence is emerging that he
was right but guess what at the time
when he said that the left called him a
conspiracy theorist all over the pages
of the mainstream media all on
television Tom cotton is a conspiracy
theorist pushing a debunked discredited
conspiracy theory right except it wasn't
debunked I guess it's being rebuffed
right now because a lot of evidence is
emerging that he was right in the media
were wrong and they were propagandizing
for China so Jim Garrity at National
Review had a great piece on this
outlining the evidence the other day and
most of the piece is quoting this guy
Matthew Tai who creates YouTube videos
and who says that he's found the source
of the corona virus here are just a
smattering of facts go watch the YouTube
video go read the piece of n are the
Wuhan Institute of biology in China
posted a job opening on November 18th
2019 so right around the time that we're
seeing this thing crop up last year
asking for scientists to come research
the relationship between coronavirus and
bats just a coincidence that probably
right that's it's just a what at what
are the odds then on December 24th 2019
the Wuhan Institute of biology posted
another job opening that said long-term
research on the pathogenic biology of
bats carrying important viruses has
confirmed the origin of bats of major
new human and livestock infectious
diseases such as SARS and SADS and a
large number of new bat and rodent new
viruses have been discovered and
identified probably just a coincidence
though I bet the Institute had no idea
what was going on it was just in the wet
markets after all just the
someone bought a bad bat at the wet
market then there were reports that a
researcher at the Wuhan Institute of AI
Rolla Jie named Wang Yan Lang is
believed by many people to be patient
zero and is believed by many people to
be dead now what did the Chinese
government say about this they said
never happened they don't know who she
is she never worked there so for the
mainstream media that's good enough
they'll just print whatever the Chinese
government wants them to print for maybe
ideological reasons and also financial
reasons because China buys up so much
American media now this this woman Wang
Yan Lang is still not listed on the
Institute website but her rather she she
is listed on the Institute website but
her photo and her biography had been
removed there's still a link there but
the link is now dead so there's clearly
a connection right South China Morning
Post which is not an anti Beijing
newspaper it's actually generally
friendly to Beijing they posted on march
13th quote according to the government
dad is seen by the post a 55 year old
from Hebei Province could have been the
first person to have contracted kovat 19
on November 17th now the Institute
denied that this person Wong Yan lang
existed then when they got called out on
that they said she did work there but
she no longer does work there and most
importantly she's not accounted for they
have no idea where she is
another report around all this time from
a Chen Wang Zhao pardon my pronunciation
who is a researcher at the Wuhan
Institute of biology said that the
director of the Institute was
responsible for leaking the corona virus
there's just another report just adding
to the mountain of evidence that may or
may not be true but a lot of its adding
up here's another crazy aspect of this
that we're getting from all these
reports we were told that the Wuhan wet
market that spread the virus was
responsible because some people hunted
bats and they sold the bats at the web
market and the bat had the disease and
the disease spread to everybody remember
the whole whole virus came from bad bat
soup don't eat bats soup don't eat
Pangolin okay now there is evidence that
the bats that carry this corona virus do
not occur naturally around Wuhan
they you can't just go to a cave in
Wuhan and hunt this bat and that's where
you're gonna get it that the bat would
have to come from someplace else maybe
through the Wuhan Institute of biology
just another strange suggestion another
researcher Shabbo Tao who goes by a
couple other names a scholar from South
China University of Technology recently
published a report that researchers at
the Wuhan virus laboratory had been
splashed with bat blood and urine and
they were quarantined for 14 days
because of some kind of accident at the
lab and then cherry on top if you don't
believe any of that you don't believe
any of these people from around the whoa
Han Institute of biology the CDC the
United States Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention and the World
Health Organization which is a China
mouthpiece could not confirm if the bats
that carry the corona virus were even
present at the wet market so now you're
talking about well a China source which
is w-h-o and a US or CDC neither of them
can confirm that the bats that spread
the disease were even there at the Wuhan
wet market all these little pieces of
evidence start to be adding up and start
to dismantle this idea that China the
government knew nothing about this
whatsoever it had nothing to do with the
Institute of biology and let me tell you
if you believe that it did you're a
crazy conspiracy theorist does that mean
that China intentionally created and
spread this disease no it doesn't have
to mean that that's not what Tom cotton
was saying in that interview ok
scientists are saying right now that the
disease doesn't look manufactured what
does that mean I have no idea but I have
no reason to dispute the scientists but
of course the virus could have occurred
naturally been brought to the Institute
of AI Rolla G to study had some accident
like the ones described in these reports
from China occur and then have the virus
leaked from the lab or it could have
been delivered I don't know but it
doesn't have to be deliberate for there
to be a connection there with the
Institute this is not a conspiracy a
conspiracy theory rather as the left
attacked Tom cotton for saying
or as the left attacked Tom cotton for
allegedly promoting okay it's a very
plausible theory actually when all of
that adds up it's just common sense even
the Washington Post now by the way the
people who were calling it a conspiracy
theory they now admit it from David
Ignatius how did co vid nineteen begin
its initial origin story is shaky US
intelligence officials don't think the
pandemic was caused by deliberate
wrongdoing the outbreak that has now
swept the world began with a simpler
story albeit one with tragic
consequences the prime suspect is
natural transmission from bats to humans
perhaps to run sanitary markets but
scientists don't rule out that an
accident at a research laboratory in
Wuhan might have spread a deadly bat
fire that had been collected for
scientific study
so they have to begin with their defense
of the Chinese government I have to
begin look at me it shouldn't it's not
deliberate okay it could have been at
the wet market even though we don't have
any evidence that the bats were even
there but okay it could have come from
this foot this research laboratory as an
accident and then unbelievably he goes
on to attack Tom cotton say it's still
kind of hold on to this conspiracy
theory idea even though what Tom cotton
said is essentially what this guy just
admitted in the Washington Post two big
takeaways here one we need to know how
the disease started if China
intentionally unleashed this thing then
we're at war if China accidentally
unleashed this thing then we're in the
most tense global conflict you can be in
short of war if it's just a coincidence
then the mainstream media still acted
recklessly to ignore all of the evidence
on the other side and dismiss even the
suggestion that there might be a link
between the Wuhan virus and the Wuhan
Institute of Virology second big
takeaway here the mainstream media will
now label anything that disputes their
narrative as a conspiracy theory I've
seen this happening recently okay it's
it's been increasing I don't like
conspiracy theories I'm in no way an
adherent to conspiracy theories I always
prefer simpler answers to things but the
left is now abusing the term conspiracy
theory in exactly the way they've abused
the terms racism and sexism and bigotry
and all of that to mean things that to
mean basically anything anything that
they don't like here's an example
I was recently doing a little research
search on cultural marxism cultural
Marxism is a more recent form of Marxism
after Karl Marx himself which applies
tenets of Marxism which would typically
apply to economics and politics to the
culture cultural Marxism has a long
intellectual pedigree
it begins most conspicuously with an
Italian thinker Antonio Gramsci
now I studied a lot of Italian
literature and Italian writing when I
was in college so I've known about
Antonio Gramsci for a long time
I was taught by mostly left-wing
professors this was you know obviously
his establishment as it gets when I was
in college right I've now learned that
the phrase cultural Marxism according to
the mainstream media is a conspiracy
theory and and most remarkably they call
it an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
because some cultural Marxists have been
Jews now most people who know nothing
about cultural Marxism who know nothing
about these writers they'll just read
then they'll say okay it's a conspiracy
theory anybody who uses that phrase is a
conspiracy theorist but if you have any
historical literacy on this topic you
know that cultural Marxism has been
around for a long time
there are many Marxists who have
referred to themselves as cultural
Marxists Marxist in it who want to apply
the tenets of Marx to the culture and
that the father of cultural Marxism
isn't Jewish he's an Italian guy named
Gramsci it's how was that anti-semitic I
guess it's anti it's hallo
it's hallo phobic maybe I guess but it's
certainly not anti-semitic but what the
mainstream media are counting on is that
you have no idea who Gramsci is who you
have no idea what Marxism is even is and
certainly as it applies to the culture
you've no idea what ideas like cultural
hegemony and the long intellectual
history of this topic is they just want
to shut up people who cut through their
own narrative ironically in this case or
perhaps expectedly in this case cultural
Marxism and it's the same thing we're
seeing here
if you cut through the mainstream
narrative which is carrying water for
China and you say you know maybe we got
to take a look at this lab that's a
couple miles away from where they say
the virus was discovered the lab that's
coronavirus advance maybe there's
something there they tell you no no way
you're a crazy conspiracy theorist well
now we've punctured that veil the only
conspiracy theories are the propaganda
being peddled by the mainstream media to
cover up for very very bad actors around
the world there's some good news that
we're seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel but now we're gonna have to look
backward and figure out who got us to
this unprecedented moment of a global
shutdown in the first place there's
going to be a lot of value placed on
hindsight and that hindsight is probably
going to determine how we look into the
future and how we look at 2020 all right
that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen